[Music]
cnn reported this week that the war in
ukraine has sent president biden into
the situation room nearly every day
incidentally the situation room is also
what chipotle calls the bathroom
you know you guys
as much as i think that's a funny joke i
feel like that punch line is well-worn
territory we get it chipotle gives you
diarrhea
you know it's just an easy joke and i'm
ashamed i made it
you know i'm vowing right now to never
make a chipotle joke again
it's a well i go to a lot it's toilet
humor and
i'm starting to feel like it's lazy so i
want to give up jokes about chipotle in
style
[Music]
i'm never gonna joke never ever gonna
joke about chipotle again
it's rude it's grass to talk about
blowing ass i vow to be a better man
chipotle's motto is food with integrity
but it should be [ __ ] happens
again
that's right i'm growing i'm evolving
and i'm moving past the need to say
things like
whenever i go to chipotle i always ask
for queso as in k so i just [ __ ] myself
good you shouldn't say that and i'll
make double sure not to say
once chipotle had me ruin the toilet so
bad they put it in the moma
no i'm never gonna joke never ever gonna
joke about chipotle again
it's rude it's grass to talk about
blowing ass i've had to be a better man
no i'm never gonna say
when the cashier asks cash or credit i
say i'm paying with my ass
again
please stop derrick i'm telling you the
things i'm not gonna say anymore i'm not
gonna say this stuff look i'll tell you
the same thing i tell the chipotle
employee every time i go
what's that there's someone in here
look
the truth is i love chipotle every time
i get drunk it's the only thing i want
[ __ ] i could tear up some chipotle right
now and i'm not even drunk
yeah i'm a little buzzed but that's not
what this is about
it's about these jokes being so unfair
so i'm done
this time i
i'm
swear
going to joke about your body baby
it's rude it's grass to talk about
blowing ass i'm about to be a bitter man
no i'm never gonna say
after i ate chipotle i took a [ __ ] so
bad it's now a texas governor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you